a news conference is underway
after that apartment building collapsed
in surfside florida dozens of families
were sleeping
as the high-rise crumbled to the ground
in just seconds early yesterday
rescuers have been working around the
clock in a desperate search for
survivors
we're joined now by the mayor of
surfside charles burkett mayor burkett
thank you so much for joining us and
again our
deepest condolences to your community
thank you uh mayor i wanted to ask you
if you have
been able to learn anything at all about
what might have caused
this collapse and whether you're at all
concerned about the surrounding
buildings
there in surf side absolutely i think
that uh
you know there there's a serious problem
buildings don't fall down in america
that's a third world phenomenon
not something that happens in the united
states
there was something seriously seriously
wrong here
um and we're going to find out what it
is but that's not going to be today
today we're going to be
trying to pull people alive out of that
rubble mayor we heard from the fire
marshal a short time ago who described
the building as
incredibly compromised we know that the
search and rescue teams
are working in in very dangerous
conditions
what what can you tell us about the
status of of the search and rescue right
now
well i was just there i ran over to to
speak with you
uh we we do have you know it's
heartbreaking because we now have a
small fire
somewhere underneath the building and
we've been working on that for a couple
days now
we've got rain that's been sort of
passing over and and making the work
area very slick and dangerous and now
we're kind of picking off
debris off the side of the building
which is sort of endangering
the uh the searchers so that's going on
but
you know the the one focus that we have
today
is to make sure that we bring people out
alive i want the
the residents i want the people who have
loved ones that they're looking for to
know that that's the only thing we're
doing
we've got crews there that you know
we've been going from seven to seven and
seven to seven and we'll keep going
until we get everybody who can be pulled
out pulled out of that building
uh it's amazing the resources that we've
been given
president biden the white house our two
senators rubio and scott
our governor who's been here debbie
wasserman schultz in the dade county
mayor cava have given us resources which
have overwhelmed us
we've actually probably got too many
resources but we don't have a resource
problem we've got a love problem we just
need to be able to focus
we need a little good weather we need a
couple good breaks
and that's that's really what we need
because we've got everything else
we just and we've also got the intention
to stay here and get the job done
mayor we know an essential part of the
search and rescue operation
is dogs who sniff out signs of life
yesterday you told us that the dogs had
zero hits
as they scrambled over the rubble any
updates today on that front
well you know i i was at it two in the
morning last night the dogs came at
about four or five i think
and they didn't have zero hits but they
had a few hits
uh you know we found the little boy and
and the woman
but uh uh it's been tough the rain makes
it tough
uh the fire certainly makes it tough um
but that doesn't mean that the search
doesn't
continue so we're going to do everything
we can
we're going to hope mother nature
cooperates and
you know we're going to just do
everything we can yeah that's the bottom
line and i want
absolutely go ahead i notice there's a
crane
over your left shoulder uh doing work on
what appears to be the top of the rubble
or is that crane taking things off the
side of the building what's that
operation we see
that that that crane is there because
apparently there were
dangerous pieces of rubble that were
possibly
likely to fall on the search and
rescuers
so what they're trying to do is make the
site safe again
so that they can get back in there and
do their jobs
mayor can you just tell us how the
families are doing that that did survive
that we know of
obviously you said the point of all of
this is to search for those lives that
could still be
uh under the rubble but what about those
who are standing by and obviously still
in shock
that they made it out alive
well you know we took 40 out yesterday
and we got them up to our community
center we relocated them to hotels
those are about 15 family units i was up
at the community center talking to the
families yesterday
and they're understandably uh
terribly upset and uh
you know i'm going back there this
morning to give them the update once i
go back i'm going to jump
back over there and and gather as much
information as i can
so i've got you know precise information
to give to the families because at the
end of the day
that's what we're here for we're here to
bring people out safely if we can and
keep the families informed
it's you know you can't imagine the pain
they're going through yeah
it is unimaginable we and as i say we we
offer our thoughts
to your community at this point you're
going through a lot mayor burkett thank
you so much
we appreciate you joining us this
morning we'll be right back your local
news
is coming up next